and for james caprilian talked about the
boston start dallas did and then his
next start how about going back home
where he grew up and of course facing
the los angeles angels of anaheim his
dad doug
got so i guess irritated he just decided
to move wherever he wanted to sit and
not worry about the family and the
friends who were there just to enjoy the
game but brilliant has done a great job
making his 12th star and he's won four
games for the athletic sub three iron
monavie cannot ask for anything more
so here's fletcher don't blink we could
have action
pulls it softly to the right side
wilson has a quick throw and
they get fletcher by a step and that's
the first out of the ball game here's
walsh 274 it's 22 home runs
could not ask for a better pitch sean
murphy wanted it about
letter high and that's exactly where he
threw it maybe just a little bit above
that max is playing in 40 games for the
halos this season ohtani's at first just
getting started two on top of the first
no score
eye in the air left center field
loriano
jose suarez on the mound for the angels
today been real solid 2.29 era very
important for suarez to get ahead of the
count and expand with his change-up
stassi setting a tight target and the
3-1 is on the ground on the left side of
the infield wren fifo for out there's
the shortstop elvis andrews now hitless
yesterday and over his last 13 at the
plate chopper over the middle and fletch
has it near the bag for round number two
four counts of matt olson three balls
and two strikes
got him he swings and misses that one he
got him on a breaking ball and that is
how the inning will end
one pitch one out and taylor ward will
be the next batter there's one that's
chopped out of the reach of the
shortstop andrews and that's going to
roll on out into left center field off
the bat a taylor ward so he has the
game's first hit today one out single
here in the second and adam eaton will
be the next batter and here's the pitch
and there's one that's bounced through
on the left side and that's going to
roll on out into left field so back to
back one out singles runners at first
and second and jose iglesias will be the
next batter
who's coming in and over and he makes
the catch so that ball really hung out
off the crack of the bat it looked like
it was going to be a hit if kenneth
was able to come in and over here's
brendo two-two fish to run he folds or
one-on-one pitch just blew it foul third
base side chapman going over he's there
and he makes the catch
chef caprilian works his way out of the
jam a couple of runners stranded and
there are two gone five in a row retired
by suarez to start the afternoon chapman
bats third here in the bottom of the
second inning
made of chase second strike out of the
game for suarez six in a row retired by
the angels lefty to start the afternoon
david fletcher leads things off here in
the angels half of ending number three a
scoreless ball game that one eats up
chapman
i don't recall ever saying that
and fletch is aboard on what should be
scored as an e5 he went back on that
baseball in the hop
stop by chapman
show he drew a four pitch walk in his
first plate appearance so he is yet to
see a strike today
it's a swing and a miss murphy's throat
he's there and that's
and it does look like his foot gets in
there and they are going to check it his
foot gets in there before the tag of
elvis andrews is on the left thigh and
his foot is already on the base
joey can even see that after he swings
the bat i mean it's okay he could do
anything and everything
it was i don't know i've been wrong
before but i think this is going to go
their way and it does so two outs and
here's stassi
two bit swinging
[Applause]
here comes a two-out rally by the angels
runners at first and second for luis
renifo here it is
and this one's gonna be playable chapman
into foul territory looking up waiting
and he's got it
look caprean gets out of another jam
three innings in a row he's worked his
way out of him
he's trying to figure out jose suarez
have not been able to do it just yet and
there's olson struck out
[Applause]
matt olson
liftoff at the coliseum
his 25th of the year and it's one
nothing oakland
mr daytime strikes again
and oakland gets the first run on this
afternoon
well i was locking stuff with the lefty
unfortunately nadio waiting on the other
side
suarez dropped that wrinkle in there and
mario got the ironing board out and
flattened it pack your bags baby
[Applause]
[Music]
the top of the sixth inning with the a's
leading one nothing
struck him out six strikeouts for the
throw
you hear the pop of the catcher's mitt
which means a good fastball elevated as
the case
last time with
stassi
so the count two and two to eaton with
the tying run at second base
strike three called on the outside
corner eaton can't believe it flips his
bat in the air
so caprilian gets out of another jam
jacob wilson leads off for the a's
spotted with a six one nothing athletics
up the middle and that'll be a big a
lead off single for jacob wilson so
first big league hit for jacob
congratulations
mistake made by suarez and he paid for
it first major league hit being all
are loaded one out for jed lowry who's
been ridiculously good in clutch
situations this year
to right field
eaton backs up
should be deep enough kemp tags kemp's
gonna come in kemp's gonna score and
it's two to nothing the a's lead so
larry does it again
mike myers comes out of the bullpen if
he is looking for more they lead two
nothing with two out in the bottom of
the sixth loriano stands in the asap
[Applause]
olsen to third now olson's gonna come
around and score as the relay throw in
just kind of trickle past a couple of
angels players
so two runs come in
mariano blisters at two base hit
off the wall and left
ken of course was going to score easily
from third olson began the sequence at
first base and when the throw came in
as the ball hit off the base of the wall
and the left fielder ward threw the ball
into second base or towards second but
it bounced his way in toward the infield
and once the ball is kind of dying katsu
had the green light for olson and he
scored and these have a four-nothing
lead so runners at first and third the
a's looking for a two-out hit from
elbows as he tries to snap a personal
low for 15.
that's gonna work
kemp's gonna score kenneth's gonna go to
third five to nothing
now olson with the scoring for the a's
with his 25th home run
and that one's gonna work a broken back
drops into center field rbi hit anders
to third
six to nothing the a's lead
during the
half inning break and it's still going
on as we speak joe madden has been in a
very heated
argument with the home plate umpire bill
miller joe's already been tossed out of
the game things are not going the way
joe would like and it's all kind of
boiled over right now as he's finally
walked out of the batter circle
so deolus guerra comes in for his 27th
appearances he will try to get the final
three outs here in the ninth inning
[Applause]
fletcher a little pop-up this should do
it folks olson in the foul territory
he's got it and that is the ball game
so the a's take the two-game series they
dominate this afternoon
and now they are set to head off on a
10-game road trip which starts thursday
night
in seattle but this afternoon here at
the coliseum the a's pick up their
eighth shutout
of the year nicely done by the a's and
the pitching staff